[Музика]
з початку повномасштабної
планки в україні навчальні
заклади зазнавали бомбардувань і щоденних смуг,
діти більше не можуть навчатися в багатьох
пошкоджених школах, тому що російські
окупанти зруйнували будівлі
закладів
замість класів у школах
стіни нещодавно  побудовані сучасні
заклади були знищені
дитячі садки перетворилися на чорні спалені
стіни також нещодавно там постраждала бійня дітей
університети, які раніше були місцем
для навчання та полігоном
для підготовки майбутніх конкурентоспроможних професіоналів
на ринку праці стали притулком
від вітру та запахів війни
[  Музика
] постраждалі від ракетно-
артилерійського обстрілу заклади щодня нагадують світові
про жорстоких вбивць, адже
знищення навчального закладу
– це знищення життя наших дітей,
усіх дітей у системі освіти
змусили одразу стати дорослими,
замість того, щоб готуватися до  випускний
і випускний  ції святкування вони об’єднали
зусилля, щоб допомогти україні зараз
студенти та науковці волонтери
збирають пожертви для армії та
представляють країну на
міжнародній арені російські
окупанти можуть зруйнувати стіни, але вони
не можуть бути цілісністю душ
викладачі продовжують свою роботу навіть
завдяки  робота і цей факт підтверджує
слух про інгредієнти
ми вдячні за підтримку
світу нашими спільними зусиллями ми
працюємо над найважливішою перемогою
та боремося за відновлення міжнародного
права кожен може допомогти у будівництві
зруйнованих дитячих садочків та
університетів кожен  може дати українським
дітям можливість здобувати
освіту вдома
в рамках ініціативи президента
Волдемора Зеленського united 24 створила
фонд підтримки освіти і
науки
можна пожертвувати міжнародну та іноземну
валюти